eine werkstatt den zwei israelis einer
jude einer araber let's talk straight
heißt das video ein schlagabtausch aus
hass und vorurteil
[Musik]
nach der mutter die unter dem motto nie
blöd dass die cola
trinkt sich die gegner gut
am riemer vitara vemap war somit und
ernstere eine provokation rassistisch
und demütigend und doch ein aufschrei
der alte denkmuster in frage stellt
ich wuchs mit diesem romantischen
vorstellungen auf die bedeutung ein jude
in seinem jüdischen heimatland zu sein
ein sehr starkes narrativ mit dem ich
auf und
sie nennen uns arabische israelis aber
der richtige ausdruck ist
palästinensische bürger israels
es wäre wirklich schön damit anzufangen
lasst uns klartext reden
[Musik]
hatte
alles seine rolle in st
[Musik]
bugri klartext heißt das rap duo
bestehend aus julia dem juden unser mehr
dem araber im wahren leben sind die
beiden ziemlich beste freunde erst über
das web projekt lernten die beiden sich
kennen
erst als der song die finale version
fertig war verstand ich dass er nicht
authentisch klingt wenn ich es allein
mache also musste ich einen partner
finden es war die interessanteste
begegnung mit einem menschen in meinem
ganzen leben ich hatte vorher nicht so
viele araber getroffen und sah nach ist
so energiegeladen so menschenfreundlich
wir fühlten uns sofort miteinander
verbunden wir schauten uns in die augen
und ich wusste der typ meint es ernst
und ehrlich er versucht nicht mich zu
benutzen als marionette als alibi araber
ich setzte ihn ein um zu sagen alles ist
gut wir werden frieden koexistenz haben
wenn er kam zu mir und sagte lasst uns
klartext reden
[Musik]
hallo sagen aber nicht nennen und die
welt kommt sie war die ag kino am arena
sagte michael riehm ihre dienste stehen
als laminat
die herkunft von moria und sein könnte
unterschiedlicher nicht sein jeder wuchs
auf mit seinem ganz eigenen und doch
typische narrativ
es ist dies ist zionistische narrativ
vom recht der juden auf ihr heimatland
menschen die verfolgt wurden und immer
wieder ziele von angriffen waren ihr
ganzes leben lang
ich wuchs mit den geschichten meiner
familie auf mein großvater war ein sehr
berühmter offizier in der israelischen
armee er kämpfte im sechs tage krieg und
gehörte zu den fallschirmjägern die
jerusalem eroberten und die israelische
flagge auf den tempelberg ist
mein archiv ist um 180 grad das
gegenteil
sein großvater hissten die flagge auf
dem tempelberg
mein großvater war in der
kommunistischen partei kämpfte für die
freiheit und versuchte palästina zu
befreien
allerdings nie gewaltsam
doch die gewalt zwischen palästinensern
und israelis scheint nie zu enden und
noch immer wird um jerusalem gekämpft
und um den tempelberg nach wochenlangen
auseinandersetzungen und provokationen
nationalistischer zionisten kommt es im
mai 2021 zum offenen krieg
die hamas in gaza eskaliert den konflikt
mit dem massiven raketenbeschuss von tel
aviv und zielen in ganz israel
tausende raketen werden wahllos auf die
städte abgefeuert nicht alle werden
abgefangen
es gibt tote und verletzte
die antwort schwere bombenangriffe der
ungleich stärkeren israelischen
luftwaffe vor allem auf die
infrastruktur der hamas in gaza
wie immer trifft es aber auch die
zivilbevölkerung mit noch mehr toten und
verletzten als in israel
dann passiert etwas womit kaum jemand
gerechnet hat die gewalt zwischen
palästinensern und israelis greift auf
ganz israel über in vielen städten mit
gemischter bevölkerung gehen menschen
aufeinander los die lange scheinbar in
frieden zusammen lebten palästinensische
israelis gegen jüdische israelis
inbody anzieht ein jüdisch zionistischer
mob durch die straßen und schlägt einen
harmlosen arabischen taxifahrer halbtot
in jerusalem entkommt er ein jude nur
knapp wütenden arabern es gibt durch
versuche zu hauf und in lot und in
anderen städten brennenden synagogen
[Musik]
zum ersten mal seit 1948 kam es zu
gewaltsamen zusammenstößen zwischen
jüdischen und arabischen bürgern
desselben staates zum ersten mal und das
ist der wichtige punkt dessen wir uns
bewusst sein müssen der ausbruch der
gewalttätigen ereignisse hat zwei ebenen
zum einen geht es um die solidarität mit
den palästinensern
insbesondere in ost jerusalem und in
gewissem maße auch mit der hamas aber
ich denke das hauptproblem ist die
zweite ebene die tiefer liegende ebene
die sozioökonomische notlage und die
situation von chaos in der arabischen
gesellschaft selbst
während des zehntägigen krieges liefern
sich arabische jugendliche jeden tag
straßenschlachten mit der polizei etwas
explodiert das sich lange angestaut hat
das tiefer geht als der aktuelle
konflikt nur eine minderheit ist
gewalttätig aber eine mehrheit fühlt
sich in ihrer identität unterdrückt
am tag des waffenstillstands stelle
nuria und sahne ihr video online es geht
sofort iran in den sozialen medien wird
es millionenfach geklickt die beiden
haben einen nerv getroffen
in dem moment in dem wir den videoclip
fertig hatten haben wir ihnen auch
veröffentlicht und das war zugleich
exakt der tag des waffenstillstands mit
gaza das timing war perfekt als hätten
die sterne günstig gestanden nach der
veröffentlichung wurde es so etwas wie
der soundtrack des konflikt der
soundtrack der unruhen und der situation
im ganzen land
für jede rasse botschaft an mich oder
ihn gab es 100 andere der liebe der
hoffnung und des wandels
vielen im land ist klar geworden so kann
es nicht weitergehen
seit 1948 gibt es den konflikt zwischen
der israelischen regierung vertreten
durch die polizei oder jemand anderen
und der palästinensischen minderheit in
israel das ist der streitpunkt das ist
das problem wir wollen das lösen wir als
als teenager wollen respekt und unser
erbe wir wollen gehört werden wir wollen
dass man uns endlich zuhört
darüber stimmt damit sprach er charlie
tahan separate nach dem krieg im
internet
[Musik]
1948 das jahr das sich ins kollektive
gedächtnis der palästinenser eingebrannt
hat sie nennen es nachbar die große
katastrophe
[Musik]
noch ist palästina mandatsgebiet der
briten doch deren abzug steht kurz bevor
seit verabschiedung des un teilungsplan
für palästina im november 1947 bekämpfen
sich palästinensische und jüdische
milizen es kommt zu massakern und
gräueltaten auf beiden seiten
[Musik]
am 14 mai 1948 dem tag des britischen
abzugs ruft ben gurion in tel aviv die
gründung israels aus nach fast zwei
jahrtausenden haben die juden wieder
einen eigenen staat der jubel kennt
keine grenzen die
palästinenser lehnen diesen staates von
vornherein ab zu einer eigenen
staatsgründung fehlt ihnen die
organisation und letztlich die
unterstützung der arabischen nachbarn
das große problem des palästinensischen
volkes war dass es nicht organisiert war
und dass anstatt der palästinenser
andere arabische länder die
verantwortung für die palästinensische
sache übernahm
diese länder haben ihre eigene agenda
die truppen sechs arabischen
nachbarstaaten marschieren am tag der
israelischen unabhängigkeitserklärung
gegen den jungen staat die juden sollen
endgültig aus palästina vertrieben
werden offiziell im interesse und für
die unabhängigkeit der palästinenser
insgeheim aber hoffen die arabischen
nachbarn auf eigene territorial gewinnen
doch das unerwartete geschieht trotz
zahlenmäßiger unterlegenheit schlagen
die israelis die arabischen truppen
zurück und erobern weitere gebiete
für die palästinensische bevölkerung
nimmt die nakba ihren lauf etwa 850.000
palästinenser werden heimatlos die
meisten fliehen vor den kriegshandlungen
viele werden von israelis aus ihren
häusern vertrieben die meisten werden
nie wieder zurückkehren
nur etwa 150 tausend palästinenser
bleiben im neuen staat israel als
feindliche volksgruppe bestenfalls
geduldet denn willkommen sie werden
später die israelische
staatsbürgerschaft bekommen doch bis
heute kämpfen ihre nachfahren um
anerkennung und gleichberechtigung
damals 1948 gab es zwei verfeindete
völker und juden bis dahin die
minderheit haben die araber bis dahin
die mehrheit als feindliches volk
wahrgenommen das ist natürlich im
hinterkopf der beiden kollektive der
beiden volksgruppen hier im staat israel
aber wir sind jetzt an einem besonderen
zeitpunkt mehr als 70 jahre nach 1948
und es scheint dass die nakba ein
bedeutender historischer moment ist der
immer noch in den köpfen vieler
arabischer bürger ist
heute leben 2 millionen arabisch
palästinensische israelis im land gut
ein fünftel der bevölkerung
fragt man die nach ihrem größten problem
dann sind es nicht die schatten der
vergangenheit
es ist auch nicht die situation ihrer
brüder schwestern in der westbank und in
gaza in einer umfrage von 2021 nannte
eine große mehrheit etwas anderes an
erster stelle
die gewalt unter arabern selbst in den
arabischen gemeinden israels sowie ein
teil einer kleinstadt nordöstlich von
tel aviv
nahe der grenze zur westbank geben hier
vor allem palästinensische israelis eine
typische gemeinde die beinahe
verschlafen wirkt doch fast jeden tag
fallen schüsse in tais oft weiß man
nicht einmal warum jeden tag steht
deshalb auch roger bali vor ihrem
kleinen laden und horcht
es gibt keine feste uhrzeit für die
schießerei es passiert jetzt oder später
jederzeit warum
weil es waffen gibt und die sind in den
händen von kindern
[Musik]
eigentlich war etwa im staat israel
angekommen sie hat den israelischen pass
und viele rechte als staatsbürgerin
theoretisch jedenfalls mit ihrem mann
und ihren kindern führt sie einen
kleinen supermarkt ihre familie hat es
zu bescheidenem wohlstand gebracht es
ging den alaba dies gut bis die gewalt
auch in ihr leben ein brach dort wo ihr
mann an der kasse sitzt erzählt roger
dass ihr sohn als ein maskierter auf ihn
schoss das ganze magazin leer roger hat
die einschläge von 25 kugeln gezählt bis
heute nur notdürftig überklebt
er hat ihn erschossen mit allem was er
hat
geraubt wird nichts aber ihr sohn hat
ist tot die überwachungskamera hat die
tat aufgezeichnet
doch obwohl wir den täter sofort
identifizieren kann dauert es monate bis
die polizei ihn verhaftet
sie hat polizei kam nach dem mord und
hat das video mitgenommen
wir haben von der ersten minute an die
polizei informiert und mit ihr
kooperieren
wir haben nichts zurück
auch die nachbarn haben der polizei all
ihre überwachungsvideos überlegen aber
die hat den täter erst nach viereinhalb
monaten verhaftet
das trauma am start verfolgt die familie
bis heute die gründe für die tat bleiben
im dunkeln eine schießerei von vielen
für radfahrer ist der wahre grund der
ihr sohn musste sterben weil die
gesellschaft die gewalt unter arabern
ignoriert
ich kann nicht sagen dass es in diesem
staat keine gesetze es gibt gesetze ja
auch gute gesetze aber die sind gegen
uns und nicht für uns
die polizei wollte die gewalt noch nie
stoppen wenn dann hätten sie es längst
getan nichts ist schwierig für israels
polizei
[Musik]
das phänomen von anschlägen und
kleinkriminalität unter den arabischen
israelis wird immer schlimmer allein
2021 wurden 127 menschen ermordet
die gewerkschafterin meister juli
beschäftigt sich seit langem mit dem
phänomen der gewalt im arabischen sektor
die ursachen dafür seien vielfältig
die gegend hier um terry ist so etwas
wie ein mikrokosmos dessen was sich in
allen gemeinden der arabischen
gesellschaft abspaltet
minella organisationen kontrollieren das
tägliche leben und die glauben wirklich
dass sie frei sind bei allem was sie tun
und sie bedrohen alle jeder fürchtet
sich es hat auch mit der
wirtschaftlichen situation zu tun wenn
die regierung nicht in die wirtschaft
hier investiert dann ist das hier
natürlich ein ort für kriminelle und die
jungen leute die für sie arbeiten und
keine vision von der zukunft haben
der start der sonst terror mit allen
mitteln bekämpft und keine gewalt in
jüdischen stätten duldet schau dem
arabischen teil der gesellschaft einfach
weg
der hauptgrund für die wachsende gewalt
und das verbrechen ist das fehlende
dagegen vorgehen der regierung
die regierung kümmert sich nicht darum
was in unserem teil der gesellschaft
passiert
manchmal denke ich als aktivistin sogar
sie sind ein chaos unter den
palästinensern interessiert nach dem
motto solange sich die palästinenser
gegenseitig umbringen sind sie in
anderen bereichen stellen
doch menschen wie water wollen nicht
länger still sein obwohl sie angst haben
ich habe angst um meine familie und mein
haus aber ich sage alles weil ich
innerlich explodiere ich kann nicht
schweigen sterben muss ich so oder so
wenn sie nicht erschießen sterbe ich ich
will nicht sterben ohne etwas zu sagen
ich kann nicht schweigen es geht um
meine kinder wer hat mehr als ich
verloren was kann ich noch verlieren
[Musik]
auch in der stadt lot ist die gewalt
nicht unter kontrolle
ministerpräsident beck selbst hat
eingeräumt dass die staatsmacht das
problem über jahrzehnte ignoriert hat
jetzt sind mittel und personal der
polizei im arabischen sektor aufgestockt
worden doch veränderungen sind noch
wenig sichtbar
die polizei kämpfe mit einer vielzahl
von strukturellen problemen erklärt
commander jäger lässt der neue chef der
verbrechensbekämpfung im arabischen
sektor was sagt er zu dem vorwurf
solange sich aber nur gegenseitig
umbringen würden kümmere dass israels
polizei nicht
das ist einer der sätze die uns sehr weh
tun und mich persönlich sehr
frustrierend man kann von der polizei
nicht erwarten aus nichts was zu
schaffen wir brauchen auch die
kooperation der araber wir brauchen auch
die kooperation der anderen ministerien
es gibt keinen unterschied zwischen
jüdischen und arabischen blut zwischen
jüdischen und arabischen mord
oft sei die polizei überfordert vom
ausmaß der gewalt esra schildert die
blutfehde zweier familien die vor einem
jahrzehnt in der örtlichen moschee
begonnen
hier kannst du nicht beten du stinkender
beduine sagte einer zum anderen gehe ich
duschen dann kannst du hier beten
das war ein konflikt nur um die ehre
dieser eine satz zu stinken der beduine
gewaschen bevor du hier rein kommst hat
eine riesen auseinandersetzung
verursacht die 13 menschen mit ihrem
leben bezahlt haben darunter auch frauen
und jugendliche die nichts verbrochen
haben
einige taten wurden nie aufgeklärt das
problem beide familien lebten wand an
wand zusammen am ende richtete die
polizei eigens eine station wenige meter
entfernt nur um die streitenden parteien
auseinanderzuhalten
[Applaus]
im moment gibt es 360 solcher offenen
konflikte wie können wir überall sein
die polizei ist klein ja man hat hier
und da verstärkt aber das reicht nicht
die frage ist wie wir die anderen
ministerien einbringen um das problem an
der wurzel zu packen
die alte hafenstadt im norden israels
sie hat schon viele herren gesehen
ägypter perser griechen
römer araber kreuzritter aus marl sie
alle kamen und gingen wieder
heiß hier hat tip ist hier aufgewachsen
als arabischer israeli kennt er die
geschichte der jahrtausend alten statt
nur zu gut
diese stadt ist fast 4000 jahre alt
viele krieger hat sie erlebt und viele
völker sind hierher gekommen die meisten
sind in ihre heimat zurückgekehrt
nachdem sie ihre kriege verloren haben
im mai 1948 eroberten israelis die stadt
auch in akko flohen damals tausende
palästinenser
1948 haben die leute gedacht dass sie
nur zwei wochen weg gehen und dann
zurückkehren aus den zwei wochen sind 73
jahre geworden
heute leben in akko araber und juden
eine gemischte statt nein das ist
eigentlich falsch es ist keine gemisch
der stadt es ist eine arabisch
islamische palästinensische stadt
erst als die jüdischen einwanderer kamen
wurde es zu einer gemischten stadt sowie
laut sammler oder yahoo
in der altstadt von akko die 2001 zum
weltkulturerbe erklärt wurde neben vor
allem araber doch es gibt einen
verdrängungswettbewerb reiche investoren
kaufen immobilien zu astronomischen
preisen die alteingesessenen
einheimischen können da nicht mithalten
und ziehen weg und auch von anderer
seite wächst der druck
die juden die früher in akko gelebt
haben hatten gute und freundliche
beziehungen zu den arabern
aber es gibt auch die anderen die aus
ideologischen gründen nach aco
übergesiedelt sind
besonders nachdem premier sharon 2006
den gazastreifen aufgegeben hatte
er hat dann die sogenannten gemischten
städte in israel als wohngebiete für die
siedler aus gaza aus gewesen um die
arabischen bewohner aus diesen städten
zu verdrängen
diese siedler haben ihre zionistische
und rassistische ideologie in die
arabischen viertel gebracht
2021 die gewalt vor allem arabische
israelis gingen auf einmal auf jüdische
bürger deuce
niemand hat das vorausgesehen nicht mal
die israelischen geheimdienste
niemand hatte eine solche explosion
erwartet
was passiert passiert wegen der
rassistischen politik
denn seit 70 jahren gibt es eine
rassistische politik in akko
es gibt vertreibung und druck
manche leute können ihre häuser nicht
reparieren und müssen mit ansehen wie
die juden alle unterstützung bekommen
und sie nicht
als größtes problem aber ist ein ganz
persönliches seine frau jana kommt aus
dschenin im westjordanland
obwohl sie seit 17 jahren mit einem
israeli verheiratet ist wird er die
staatsbürgerschaft
weigert das sogenannte bürgerschafts
gesetz schränkt den zuzug von
palästinensern aus der westbank und gaza
ein und obwohl das gesetz von der neuen
regierung zunächst nicht erneuert wurde
blieb alles beim alten ghana hat kein
dauerhaftes bleiberecht deshalb auch
keine arbeit keine krankenversicherung
keine sozialleistungen nicht mal auto
darf sich erfahren
jedes jahr muss ich meine
aufenthaltserlaubnis neu beantragen
jedes mal kann es sein dass ich keine
neue mehr bekommen immer wenn meine
befristete erlaubnis ab läuft werde ich
ganz aufgeregt nervös und kraftlos weil
ich angst habe dass sie mir vielleicht
keine mehr ausstellen
die jahrelange unsicherheit hat lana und
ihren ehemann zermürbt
alles an diesem leben ist provokation es
gibt keine sicherheit immer bin ich
nervös manchmal träume ich dass soldaten
in unser haus eindringen und mich zum
checkpoint an die grenze bringen seit 16
jahren leide ich darunter
dieses bürgerschafts gesetzt wirkt sich
sehr stark auf mein leben aus es ist als
ob es still steht als würdest du den
fahrer eines ferrari sagen er solle so
langsam fahren wie ein esel läuft es
verschiebt sich alles wegen dieses
gesetzes
um eine wirtschaftliche situation ist
schwierig und meine psychische
verfassung auch
es gibt keine sicherheit
vielleicht bekommt lana nächstes jahr
keine erlaubnis dann wird unsere familie
zerstört
auch die kinder spüren die ungewissheit
und leiden unter verlustängsten
ich fühle dass seit ich klein war einmal
habe ich meiner mutter nach der schule
gesagt sie solle nicht nach berlin in
die westbank fahren weil die israelis
sie vielleicht dort verhaften ich kann
nicht verstehen was der unterschied
zwischen palästinensischen bürgern und
israelischen bürgern ist soll dass die
religion oder die sprache sein
das sind doch alles keine gründe das ist
rassismus
wohl an die 30.000 familien in israel
teilen das schicksal von lana und heiß
hier die beiden wissen nicht wie es
weitergeht trotzdem versuchen sie nicht
alle israelis über einen kamm zu scheren
ich sage nicht dass alle jahren
kriminell oder ungerecht sind es gibt
viele gute juden wir sind mit vielen
befreundeten hoch anständig sind
ich habe nur etwas gegen zionisten
hoffnung gibt es immer ich verliere die
hoffnung seit 16 jahren nicht ich habe
immer an ein schönes sprichwort geklappt
morgen wird noch schöner nie habe ich
aufgegeben ich bin nicht pessimistisch
morgen wird noch schöner
[Musik]
ein traum voller zuversicht aber einer
der nur wenige monate später zerplatzen
wird
[Musik]
vor der knesset in jerusalem hat sich
eine gruppe von demonstranten versammelt
auch hier ist dabei und protestiert
lautstark gegen das bürgerschafts gesetz
es liegt der knesset erneut vor und wird
wenige tage später verabschiedet werden
da es hier ahnt bereits seine niederlage
seine frau ist gar nicht erst mit
gekommen sie habe keine kraft mehr zu
kämpfen sagt heiß hier sie habe
aufgegeben
es ist ein tödlicher frust den wir haben
wir sind die familien die seit vielen
jahren gegen dieses gesetz kämpfen ich
kann diesen frust verstehen weil viele
familien auch meine vorausgesagt haben
dass dieses gesetz wahrscheinlich durch
die knesset kommen wird
meine frau und meine kinder sind
frustriert sie sagen papa das ist ein
verlorener kampf wieso kämpfst du weiter
sie sagen mir du bist wie don quichotte
du kämpfst gegen windmühlen das ist ein
rassistischer staat er wird uns nie
rechte geben
[Musik]
sahm und korea haben sich
weiterentwickelt dass rap duo hat ein
neues video herausgebracht fischern ihm
umfasst wir können nicht atmen eine
referenz an icann brief die
amerikanische bürgerrechtsbewegung
[Musik]
drastisch einem anfasst
und ducrey sucht jetzt den direkten
kontakt zum publikum zum ersten mal in
einen club
[Musik]
das sputnik gehört zu den angesagten
clubs in tel aviv das junge publikum
hier ist offen für neues denken
[Applaus]
sie behaupten nicht dass sei die lösung
sie sagen hier ist ein tisch an dem wir
sitzen und reden können über die
schmerzlichen dinge blut und tränen
werden fließen aber wir können reden
dieses projekt wird einfluss haben ich
sehe da viel hoffnung weil es ins herz
trifft das ist etwas was gehört werden
ist etwas das gesagt werden muss mit
mundpropaganda und mit hilfe der medien
wird es gelingen
bei vielem was wir tun verbinden wir
musik kunst und bildung miteinander das
ist eine herausforderung wir wollen die
aufmerksamkeit der leute wir wollen spaß
machen und cool sein und gleichzeitig
tiefgründig und den finger in die wunde
legen das ist eine echte herausforderung
unsere herangehensweise ist echt bleiben
authentisch
hier treffen die beiden auf ein eher
wohlwollendes die beraters publikum aber
erreichen sie auch die hardliner
nur her damit wir werden mit allen
fertig das ist ja unser hauptziel nicht
in unserer komfortzone zu bleiben
sondern die leute zu konfrontieren die
mit dieser idee nicht vertraut sind oder
mit uns als freunde nicht als ein
palästinenser oder ein jude als ein als
teenager oder ein israeli sondern als
menschen als zwei menschen die etwas in
israel verändern wollen also wir sind
bereit
sicher man fasst es
ist eine karge landschaft und doch
abwechslungsreich und voll erhabener
ausblicke die wüste nägel mit 60 prozent
macht sie den größten teil des
israelischen staatsgebiets aus und doch
neben hier nur etwa zehn prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung
südlich der großstadt der schäfer finden
sich meist kleine siedlungen seit über
1000 jahren siedeln beduinen erlege
die zeugnisse ihrer uralten kultur haben
es schwer neben den ausufernden bauten
des modernen industrie staates zu
bestehen auf dem gelände eines alten
friedhofes stört ein wasserwerk die
totenruhe
nur wenig deutet heute noch auf ein
begräbnis fällt hin dass es den friedhof
überhaupt noch gibt ist im engagement
von kate aller familien zu verdanken
seit langem kämpft der arzt für die
rechte der beduinen
das ist der friedhof unserer urahnen es
geht ihnen seit hunderten von jahren
hier sind meine großeltern begraben nach
diesem friedhof wurde unser dorf benannt
raschem seine
es ist der älteste friedhof in der
ganzen umgebung
seit den 50er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts versuchen die israelischen
behörden die zersplitterten siedlungen
der beduinen aufzulösen und sie in
größere gemeinden umzusiedeln doch die
wollen bleiben und so leben wie es ihrer
traditionellen lebensweise entspricht
trotz jahrzehnten vor der schikane
der staat reagiert indem er ihnen die
entwicklungsmöglichkeit nimmt so blieb
die infrastruktur von raschem seine in
einem erbärmlichen zustand was an
straßen direkt neben dem perfekt
asphaltierten highway liegt verdient den
namen nicht mehr als
schrittgeschwindigkeit geht er nicht
wir wollen diese straße reparieren aber
die behörden erlauben uns das bisher
nicht
sie betrachten diese straße als illegal
[Musik]
und die firmen die traktoren und
bulldozer haben wollen nicht herkommen
weil die behörden oft ihrer ausrüstung
konfiszieren wenn sie hier arbeiten
aus sicht der behörden ist kaum etwas
legal in raschem seine keine der
einfachen hütten kein zelt hat eine
baugenehmigung immer wieder werden
behausungen kurzfristig abgerissen
auch die notdürftig errichtete moschee
ist illegal
gerne würden die dorfbewohner eine neue
bauen doch wie ohne genehmigung
wir wollen ja nach den vorschriften
bauen und nach den gesetzen leben wir
wollen alles im gesetzlichen rahmen
machen wir stellen uns nicht gegen das
gesetz aber das gesetz erkennt uns nicht
an das ist der urgrund aller probleme
[Musik]
den beduinen bleibt nur zu improvisieren
doch der wunsch nach besseren
lebensbedingungen mit strom oder gar
fließend wasser lässt sich nur unter
großen schwierigkeiten realisieren er
zeigt wie es noch vor gar nicht so
langer zeit war da bediente sich das
ganze dorf aus diesem brunnen für die
beduinen ist aber noch viel mehr
dieser brunnen ist ein symbol für unsere
gemeinde jetzt nicht mehr in betrieb
aber wir schätzen ihn als denkmal denn
er ist ein beweis für unsere existenz es
gibt ihn seit hunderten von jahren es
war lange die einzige trinkwasserquelle
in dieser region
vor einigen jahren haben sie uns eine
wasserleitung gelegt aber nur bis zur
hauptstraße von dort transportieren wir
das wasser mit eigenen rohren weiter wir
haben alles in privatinitiative
installiert
und dann hat das dorf noch einen traum
ein eigenes gemeindezentrum mit
dorfschule sozialstation und
medizinische ambulanz den bauplatz dafür
gibt es schon
das ist sehr wichtig für die bewohner in
diesem gebiet besonders für die kranken
weil sie darunter leiden immer in die
benachbarten kliniken fahren zu müssen
oder nach der schaefer
kariert findet das nicht zu viel
verlangt als arabischer israeli sieht er
sich nicht in opposition zum start
sondern als einen teil davon
leider fühlen wir uns sehr oft als
bürger zweiter oder dritter klasse oder
noch schlechter
wir sind aber israelische bürger wir
besitzen die staatsbürgerschaft den
personalausweis und den pass
deshalb wollen wir auch die gleichen
rechte haben wie alle bürger dieses
staates
[Musik]
mit der neuen regierung ist bewegung in
die beduinen frage gekommen etwas rasch
in sahne wurde als eine von drei
beduinen siedlungen anerkannt 35 weitere
hofften vergeblich darauf doch die sache
hat einen pferdefuß
denn aus sicht der beduinen behörde im
fernen berger sind die bewohner viel zu
weitläufig über ein großes gebiet
verteilt nach wie vor will die regierung
die weit verstreuten siedlungen der
beduinen konzentrieren
man braucht ein minimum an bevölkerung
für die wirtschaftlichkeit einer
siedlung man kann keine neue siedlung
für nur 50 familien entwickeln
man kann auch keine siedlung für 500
familien entwickeln die über 10.000
quadratkilometern verstreut leben
also verhandeln wir mit ihnen dass sie
alle zusammen an einen ort ziehen
dann erst empfehlen wir eine neue
siedlung anzuerkennen
für fasching sonne hätte das
einschneidende konsequenzen
die einwohner von raschem sanaa erleben
heute verstreut über dieses gebiet hier
und auch hier entlang des highway number
6 alle müssen sich auf eine siedlung in
einem gebiet von etwa 3000
quadratkilometer beschränken
das heißt von 15.000 auf 3000
quadratkilometer
11.000 quadratkilometer gehen zurück an
den start
doch damit liegt die groß angekündigte
anerkennung der beduinen siedlung auf
eis die bewohner fühlen sich getäuscht
für uns hat sich nichts geändert es gibt
weiterhin die zerstörung von häusern und
weiter abbruch befehle für häuser wie
gehabt
wir haben bis jetzt keine vereinbarung
erreicht über den umfang der fläche
unseres dorfes
unsere leute wollen in raschem seine
bleiben wir haben kein land aufgegeben
und wir werden keines aufgeben
wir verlangen die anerkennung unseres
gesamten landes
der mann der sich anschickt
grundlegender als alle politiker vor ihm
etwas an der lage der arabischen
minderheit zu verändern heißt man so
aber chef der arabisch islamischen
partei an abbas ist religiös konservativ
und warten doch so etwas wie eine kleine
revolution
zum ersten mal in der geschichte israels
trat
2021 unter seiner führung eine arabisch
israelische parteien eine regierung ein
und handelte milliarden an geldmitteln
für seine klientel aus dennoch viele
juden misstrauen ihm manche aber
schimpfen ihn verräter
ich kann nicht versprechen dass wir in
wenigen tagen und monaten die probleme
und die diskriminierung lösen können die
sich seit vielen jahren im staat israel
gegen die arabische gesellschaft
angesammelt haben
wir gehen einen schritt nach dem anderen
[Musik]
es gibt keinen zweifel dass diese
politik in die richtige richtung geht es
gibt allerdings viele schwierigkeiten
weil es ein neuer weg ist
keiner hat das je versucht aber wir
werden diesen weg weiter gehen
als während der unruhen
2021 arabische israelis synagogen in
brand steckten besuchte abbas
demonstrativ den rabbi der synagoge von
lot doch nationalistische zionisten
erkennen solche friedenszeichen nicht an
diese parteien in der opposition üben
sehr großen druck auf die öffentliche
meinung aus
[Musik]
sie werfen uns vor eine fünfte kolonne
zu sein oder dass wir den staat israel
schwächen
manchmal diffamieren sie uns sogar als
terroristen oder terror unterstützer und
vieles mehr
aus unserer sicht tun sie das nur weil
sie die macht verloren haben aber
auch vielen arabischen israelis fällt es
schwer eine neue rolle einzunehmen
abbas findet dass der identitätskonflikt
kein unlösbarer sein muss
wir sind in diese komplizierte
politische situation hinein geboren wir
gehören zum palästinensischen volk und
zur arabischen nation
aber auf der anderen seite ist unsere
zivile zugehörigkeit durch unsere
staatsbürgerschaft heute die zum staat
israel
die balance zwischen beiden zu finden
heißt nicht eine seite ganz auszulöschen
sammel und korea auf dem markt von ramon
ram ist hier aufgewachsen in einer art
mikrokosmos der israelischen
gesellschaft
hier leben menschen mit den
verschiedensten wurzeln zusammen
jüdische
palästinensische europäische russischen
alle mit eigener sprache kultur
tradition
wenn man sammelt nach seiner identität
fragt antwortet er so
ich bin ein mensch das ist es woran ich
seit zwei jahren wirklich ernsthaft
glaube besonders seit kuwait ich
respektiere meine palästinensischen
wurzeln meine israelische
staatsbürgerschaft ein araber zu sein
aus rammler zu sein was auch immer das
wichtigste für mich aber ist einfach ein
mensch zu sein
das wichtigste ist die unterschiede zu
verstehen und zu respektieren
erschaffen sich nahe zu sein ohne exakt
gleich zu sein und das ist ganz generell
die eigentliche geschichte der
israelischen gesellschaft da sind nicht
nur araber und juden und sondern auch
ethiopia großen menschen aus osteuropa
das ist die geschichte der juden und ich
denke das gleiche gilt für die araber
es ist eine komplexe gesellschaft und
sie macht es einem nicht leicht
anzukommen seinen platz zu finden
ich habe meinen platz noch nicht
gefunden noch nicht es gibt immer noch
hürden und probleme die überwunden
werden müssen es ist kompliziert und
bleibt es seit tag eins das ist was du
dir also und ich sagen unser leben ist
kompliziert es ist nicht schwarz-weiß es
ist eine verrückte skala manchmal fühlt
man sich angekommen manchmal weniger
vielleicht gelingt ja auch der
israelischen gesellschaft eines tages
das was amerika geschafft haben hass und
vorurteile überwinden
[Musik]